women when they have children actually
prioritize the children first and
foremost one of the priorities is
becoming then super cautious of the man
that she allows to enter into the man's
world if she's a really good mother she
TS to keep a good co-parenting
relationship with the ex and a lot of
men don't feel comfortable with that but
the true good woman like the single mom
that you should be looking for is the
one that's got a good relationship with
her ex-husband what men do is they
prefer the woman that has no contact
with the ex and the kids have never seen
the ex and they think oh I'll go for
that girl at least the baby father is
not around that's a signal that she
deprives or prevents children from
connecting with their father that's not
a good thing that's not a green flag
that's actually a red flag so what men
are doing is sometimes they're selecting
women and thinking she's got children
but she she doesn't let the kids see
their dad and they're not in his life
and he was a bum but what does that tell
you about her selection process and what
does that tell you about her ability to
co-parent it's an insight into what
would happen if you two broke up